الخطوط الجوية الأمريكية بمراجعة مقطع
فيديو انتشر على نطاق واسع على تيك توك يظهر
كرسيًا متحركًا لأحد الركاب وهو يصطدم بمدرج
المطار ويمكنك رؤيته وهو ينهار
ويرتد فوق حاجز معدني،
وقد لفت الانتباه متجددًا إلى
المصاعب التي يواجهها
المسافرون المعاقون، أصدرت الخطوط الجوية الأمريكية مقطع فيديو
بيان يقول في جزء منه أن هذه
الصورة المرئية تثير قلقًا عميقًا ونحن نقوم
بجمع المزيد من التفاصيل حتى نتمكن من
معالجتها مع فريقنا، وسنواصل
العمل الجاد لتحسين
تعاملنا مع الأجهزة المدعومة بالمساعدة
عبر شبكتنا، كما وعدوا أيضًا
بتركيب محركات الكراسي المتحركة و  المصاعد في
المطارات التي بها حركة مرور عالية لأجهزة التنقل
ولكنها لم تقدم جدولًا زمنيًا
لذلك